[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right juicy fruit juicy fruit uh
where do you where did you grow up where
you from
um lats california and tell me about
your family you had both your parents
when you were a kid
um no who raised you
well i was in our um foster care and
group homes
where was mom and dad uh
i really don't know i only see my mother
so often so
but my mother was alcoholic my dad was
too busy running the streets green
ringer and everything
how was your childhood pretty messed up
what kind of stuff went on um
said i got raped for like 10 years
in the foster system right who
by um one of the guys that actually
worked in the house
did you say anything to anyone i tried
nobody really believed me
about it right
what did i do
oh
well i just went around from um foster
home group homes
and
had somebody set my bed on fire
while i was anywhere i'll sleep
i'm sorry while i was asleep at the what
was it the group home because
yeah the group home
[Music]
i hate talking about this
if you'd rather not it's okay
i'll pay you either way
i finished
what's the next question so
you're molested for 10 years in the
foster home was was there any other
abuse
well basically with this guy that used
to come
they had a day shift an evening shift
and he had a night shift
this one guy will come in my room come
get me
basically you chain me up like a dog
this started what age when i was like
what 12 13.
that's right so so you went on your own
at what age
well often out i was on my own basically
from time i was about what 10
to [ __ ] took them at 18.
i was off and on between group homes on
the street foster homes
getting out of jail
and you started working as a prostitute
what age
12
12. i were you doing that on your own or
with him
yeah i had a plan
yeah i had my daughter when i turned
right before i turned
18 i was still out there making money
i almost lost her to the system because
my mom
basically had come back in contact with
her my mom tried to take my daughter
away from me
but because she tried to say i was on
basically on drugs and everything
like i might smoke weed but that's
somebody
i went through court back and forth with
that for a long time
and then i have my son
[Music]
when i was about to turn 22
still working the streets
i almost lost my son when i was pregnant
turning the date what happened
dude sucked me my stomach so hard
after i got finished handling business
he took the money back
they just left me there
i was seven and a half months
so they ended up having to do an
emergency c-section
he came i was at four pounds eight
ounces
basically he couldn't come home the day
that i left from the hospital
he had to stand there two extra months
you still have your kids you do you're
raising them
good p.m
um
[Music]
tell me about your kids
well my dad is going to be 17 next year
she's 16 right now
my son is 14.
they're good kids very smart
i just don't want my daughter to be like
me
do you think there's a chance of her
doing the same thing
i hope not
ugh
i don't want her to follow anything in
the same footsteps that i did
does she know what you do for work i
don't lie to my kids about anything
i don't know the truth about everything
i love my kids to death i would do
anything for him
and you're still working today do you
make enough money to
support your family almost
it's still a very dangerous way to make
a living you have kids to come home to
and support
yeah because every time i go out there i
think am i gonna make it back to my kids
or not
tell me about the guys that are your
customers
oh lord
you have to deal with these guys
different attitudes
you have some that might be nice but
very few
you have some that are pretend to be
nice
how you saying once you finish finish
handling whatever business you have to
handle with them
it's like they want to take the money
back or they want half of it back
i'm like what
i've had to stop a guy in a leg before
because you basically tried to hold me
down afterwards
and
thought he was going to get his money
back he thought he was going to put
hands on me
i've been drugged by a car before
on my stomach a whole block
just the beginning of this year i've
been hit by a car
and i've been shocked
but at the end of the day if i don't
make money
can't support me and my kids
at the end of the day i still have to go
out there and do what i have to do
so it's like you can't let stuff scare
you when you out there
because should you let it scare you how
can you make money
and because i have my kids to support
i have to do what to do
are you using drugs i smoke weed
how do you think living this life
working the streets
has changed you all these years
um i think it's changed me a lot
how do you think it's changed you
i think it's changed me a lot because
basically if everything doesn't happen
to me
wouldn't have happened to me it wouldn't
be the person i am today also
because i gained a lot of street smarts
not only do i have book smarts
i was tree smarts too so made me a lot
smarter
basically being in the streets
because like a lot of times i know what
to look for
before i get in the car use your
intuition exactly
my first mind so what kind of stuff do
you
shy away from too fidgety too anxious
for me to get in the car um two
like flashing your money too much
that's like that's bell ringers right
there
because it's like nine times out of ten
they're going want to pull into an alley
or something like that or in front of
somewhere dark where they can't nobody
see in the car or anything
and that's about 10 they gonna rape you
or try to kill you
i've been kidnapped by pants
i've been kidnapped by a pimp before to
where my kids thought i was dead
they had me in a cage
they fed me like an animal
they had a shark color around my neck
how do you think girls get so
brainwashed
to work with the pimp because they
believe that these dudes love them
but in all honesty these dudes they
don't really love them
they love the money that they get them
they how you say these guys out here
they learn
how to finesse a female tells people
what she wants to hear
and whatever that he thinks she wants to
hear that's what he's going to tell her
whatever sounds good
they'll play with your emotions and your
feelings
so they can get what they want and then
when their use of you is over
they hey they go to the next one
and they'll still try to strengthen
what advice would you give to a young
girl who's considering doing this kind
of work
don't do it stay in school
you know get good grades don't ditch
class
just listen to your parents
and don't do drugs at all period
not even weed
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your years of doing this
be careful who you trust
you have to be very careful
do you think this kind of work has
changed the way you view men
yeah in what way
to where i don't even
like i'm bisexual i used to be
like gay i used to just do this out here
like for the money
but it's like dudes it's like i don't
even like either now and i was like
just everybody leave me alone
it's like this [ __ ] that made me hate
people so bad it's like
damn
the only reason i'm still living and
going to life is because my kids
they give me a reason to wake up in the
morning
uh
my kids name is lanita smith and my son
name is jesse jesse lynn
you're proud of your kids you're proud
of your kids
i'm very proud
you should be proud of yourself too
though
i do the best i can
you're trying to protect them from the
same things you went through
you never had parents
have you ever been alone
hell no what i thought was that
what i thought was love
do you think love exists do you think
love exists
true though
i really don't
because anybody can say i love you
what really matters is i'll tell you
like this
hit rock bottom when you hit rock bottom
then you'll see who really loves you you
never know who really loves you or who's
really there for you
until you really need somebody
all right juicy fear thank you so much
for sharing your story
thank you
i'm gonna take care of you have a nice
you'll make some nice money this weekend